economía en france 24 para ello ya me
acompaña en el estudio les méndez luis
una muy buena noche de bienvenido
iniciamos hablando de la caída que
sufrieron los mercados en la jornada de
este lunes así es raúl una situación que
se presenta como consecuencia del temor
que representa el avance en los
contagios por kobe 19 con la variante
delta en casi la mayor parte del mundo
las bolsas registraron su peor caída en
nueve meses básicamente por la
incertidumbre en la manera como la
variante delta podría afectar el proceso
de recuperación económica en las
jornadas empresas del sector turismo
fueron las que resultaron más afectadas
debido al temor de nuevas restricciones
que podrían impactar en la temporada de
verano en españa por ejemplo la
aerolínea iag propietaria de british
airways e iberia cayó un 5,5 por ciento
mientras que en estados unidos united
airlines american airlines y carnival
cayeron alrededor del 4%
precisamente el dow jones el principal
indicador de wall street cerró la
jornada con una caída de 2.09 por ciento
el standard and poor's
hasta compuesto cerraron con caídas de
159 y 16 respectivamente en europa el
mayor impacto lo sufrió la bolsa de
milán con un retroceso de 3 34% mientras
que el dax alemán sufre un revés de 2 62
% en asia el nikkei 225 de japón
finalizó con una caída de 1.25 por
ciento en américa latina' la bolsa
chilena fue la única que salvó cerrar en
rojo con un alza de 1.91 por ciento en
argentina el impacto causó un alza en el
riesgo país de 1 7% hasta los mil 621
puntos y seguimos con un informe de
empleo emitido por la oit de louis en
este se centró en las dificultades que
podrían experimentar las mujeres para
recuperar la tasa de empleo en
encontrada en el período antes de la
pandemia de acuerdo con el análisis la
crisis ampliará la brecha de
desigualdades de género ya que las
mujeres han sufrido una pérdida de
empleos e ingresos desproporcionada
debido a su presencia en los sectores
más
por el brote para el organismo en 2021
habrá 13 millones menos de mujeres
empleadas esto en comparación con el año
2019 por otro lado el continente
americano es el que mayor pérdida de
empleo registra entre las mujeres con un
94 por ciento por lo que es la
organización internacional del trabajo
estima que solamente el 46 8% de estas
mujeres tendrá un empleo este año en el
continente y los precios de petróleo
sufre una caída durante la jornada
así es raúl pero más allá de lo ocurrido
por los mercados con el temor a la
expansión de la variante de alta los
precios se vieron impactados por el
acuerdo alcanzado entre los países
productores agrupados en la opep los
porcentualmente el barril de petróleo
perdió entre 675 y 7,5 por ciento es
decir el crudo brent cerró la jornada a
68 puntos 62 dólares mientras que el
west texas se ubicó en 66 puntos 42
dólares luego de varios días de
conversaciones lideradas por arabia
saudita y emiratos árabes unidos-
algunos países productores
acordaron el incremento en 400 mil
barriles al día a partir de agosto para
nivelar los precios en el mercado y
hablemos ahora entonces del crecimiento
económico de china y es que de acuerdo
con datos de la comisión nacional de
desarrollo y reforma de china durante el
primer semestre de 2021 la nación
mantuvo constante su proceso de
recuperación de acuerdo al portavoz de
esta comisión el pib de china se
expandió un 12.7 por ciento más que en
el mismo período del año pasado a nivel
trimestral aumentó un 0.4 por ciento en
el primero y 1.3 por ciento en el
segundo
veis que nos viene como si fuera el día
ya para finalizar este martes 10 pesos
viajará al espacio siendo el segundo
millonario en hacerlo tras richard
branson pro hay que señalar que vendió
uno de los asientos o fue subastado este
es mejor dicho en 28 millones de dólares
por otro lado de ese monto 19
organizaciones que están en favor y la
protección del espacio recibirán
alrededor de un millón de dólares el
resto se irá para las investigaciones
del programa de besòs en el espacio así
entonces raúl que sigue la carrera del
turismo espacial así es y vamos a ver
entonces cómo le va a 10 a jeff bezos en
este viaje espacial que va a realizar el
día de mañana muchísimas gracias como
siempre por toda la información
económica ustedes también gracias
continúen con nosotros
[Música]
i